Pressão baixa, qual seria a causa e como
normalizar? Sabe aquela tontura quando
você levanta rápido a cama, a visão dá
uma escurecida e parece que o chão ficou
mais longe. Pois é. Hoje a gente vai
conversar olho no olho sobre pressão
baixa, quando é normal, quando é sinal
de alerta e principalmente o que fazer
no dia a dia para colocar a pressão de
volta aos trilhos com abordagem prática
humana e claro na visão integrativa.
Antes de tudo, pressão baixa não é igual
pessoa doente. Tem gente que tem 9 por6,
90 por 60, que vive de maneira ótima,
sem nenhum problema, sem nenhum sintoma.
O que preocupa hipotensão sintomática,
aquela que dá tontura, fraqueza, visão
turva, desmaio, confusão, náusea. E
existe um tipo bem comum que é
hipotensão ortostática, quando a gente
perde a pressão quando ela cai ao ficar
de pé. Clinicamente considera-se uma
queda de pelo menos 20 mm de mercúrio na
sistórica ou 10 mm de mercúrio na
diastórica dentro de 1 a 3 minutos em
pé. Então, respira comigo e pensa numa
cena simples. Você ficou um tempo
sentado ou sentada, levanta de uma vez e
o sangue desce pras pernas. Se o corpo
não reage contraindo os vasos e
acelerando um pouco o coração, a pressão
despenca. Isso pode acontecer por
desidratação, calor intenso, depois de
uma virose com diarreia, por efeito de
remédios, após refeições grandes a
famosa queda pós-prandial ou por
disfunção do sistema nervoso autônomo,
mais comum em idosos, em pessoas com
diabetes de longa data ou doença de
Parxon. Alguns medicamentos entram forte
nessa história, sejam antihipertensivos
em excesso, diuréticos, nitratos, certos
antidepressivos, especialmente os
tricíclicos, antipsicóticos e até
remédios para ereção quando combinados
com nitratos. Vale revisar sua lista de
remédios com carinho. Talan, como é que
eu normalizo isso no meu dia a dia?
Vamos por partes do básico avançado com
pausa estratégica para você ir testando.
Primeiro pilar, hidratação inteligente,
água barata e funciona inclusive de
forma aguda. Um bolos, né, uma
quantidade de uma vez de 350 500 ml de
água pode elevar discretamente a pressão
e ajudar a segurar a onda em quem tem
tendência a queda. Dica prática. Acordo
tonto. Toma 300 a 500 ml de água
sentado, espera uns minutinhos e depois
levante. Em dias quentes, capricha nos
eletrólos, que são os minerais só de
potássio, com orientação e evite o
álcool excessivo. Segundo pilar, mover
sem pressa e treinar as bombas
musculares. Levante devagar, deite,
sente, aí você fica em pé. Se sentir a
tontura vindo, faça manobras
antigravitacionais.
Cruzar as pernas,
contrair forte, agachar um pouco,
apertar uma bola na mão, contrair os
glúteos e abdômen. Essas manobras
aumentam o retorno de sangue do coração
e conseguem abortar episódios de desmaio
em muita gente. Treino de resistência
para pernas e panturrilhas, caminhadas e
agachamentos ajudam a longo prazo. É a
musculatura virando aliada da sua
pressão. Terceiro pilar, alimentação
esperta, principalmente se a sua pressão
cai depois de refeições. Refeições muito
grandes e muito ricas em carboidrato
tendem a puxar sangue pro intestino e a
pressão despenca. Teste por uma semana.
Porções menores. Distribua em quatro a
cinco refeições. Reduza o pico de
carboidrato simples no almoço. Mas com
calma. Evite o álcool. Em alguns casos
selecionados estratégias como cafeína
antes da refeição ou até a carbose, que
é um remédio, pode ajudar a segurar a
queda pósplandial. Quarto pilar, com
pressão certa, no lugar certo, meia
elástica que termina no joelho, costuma
ajudar pouco. O que realmente faz
diferença é a compressão que pega a coxa
e quando indicado a cinta abdominal,
pensa nela como um cinto antigravidade.
Isso reduz o acúmulo de sangue no
abdômen, nas pernas, quando você fica de
pé. Use especialmente situações gatilho,
seja fila longa, ambiente quente ou dias
de crise. Quinto pilar, sono ambiente.
Calor de lata os vasos. Então, climatize
o quarto nas outras mais quentes, troque
banho pelando por morno e evite levantar
correndo da cama. Planeje tarefas
intensas para horários mais frescos do
dia. Hidrate-se mais quando estiver
tomando diurético em jejum prolongado na
TPM ou após treino pesado. Agora, do
lado da visão integrativa, é jogo limpo,
investigar e corrigir causas de fundo.
Aqui entra um checkup objetivo,
hemograma, ferritina, porque a anemia da
tontura e pode derrubar pressão.
são os minerais e de função rinal,
glicemia, hemoglobina glicada para ver
se não tem uma neuropatia do diabetes
que pode causar hipotensão ortostática.
Vitamina B12 porque quando ela tá baixa
pode bagunçar o sistema nervoso autônomo
e favorecer as quedas de pressão. V a
função tireodiana e em casos específicos
o cortisol matinal, principalmente
salivar, se houver perda de peso
inexplicada.
Esclorescimento da pele e faz intenso
também levam a pensar nesse exame ou
pressão muito baixa persistentemente.
Ajustar remédios que baixam demais a
pressão também é parte essencial do
plano. E quando o estilo de vida não dá
conta, então aí vai entrar as opções
farmacológicas, sempre com
acompanhamento médico. Midodrina,
droxidopa,
são alguns remédios para uso em proteção
ortostática neurogênica. Fludrocortisona
pode ajudar a aumentar o volume
intravascular, mas pede vigilância por
retenção de líquidos, que pode acontecer
também pode dar potássio baixo e aumento
da pressão ao deitar. Você pode usar
também os remédios naturais como
licorcio, alcaçus em cenários
selecionados, a pirido stigmina pode
somar. O recado é remédio certo na dose
certa pro caso certo e monitorando na
pressão deitada, porque alguns desses
fármacos podem deixar a pressão alta
quando você se estica no sofá. Deixe de
entregar um mini protocolo prático para
salvar nos favoritos e os amanhã mesmo.
Ao acordar, sente na cama, faça cinco
respirações profundas, alongue
panturrilhas, beba de 300 a 500 ml de
água. No café da manhã, porção moderada
de carboidratos, inclua proteína e
gordura boa. Na manhã, se for ficar em
pé muito tempo, use meia de compressão
até a coxa e, se recomendado, use a
cinta abdominal. Ao sentir a tontura,
cruze as pernas, contraia a forte por
30, 45 segundos e se não resolver, sente
ou deite com as pernas elevadas, tome
água. No almoço, prato dividido, metade
de vegetais, 1/4 de proteína, 1/4
carboidrato. Evite soneca logo depois de
comer e caminhe de 5 a 10 minutos
depois. Tarde quente, redobre
hidratação. Se você usa o diurético,
converse com o médico sobre horários e
doses. À noite, faça reversões pequenas,
organize o quarto fresco, evite levantar
de forma brusca de madrugada. E os
sinais de alerta. Se a pressão baixa
vier com dor no peito, falta de ar,
confusão, febre alta, vômitos
persistentes, intensa, sangramentos,
palidez acentuada, desmaios repetidos ou
ingestantes, como está importante, é
emergência. Nessas situações, a
prioridade é tratar a causa, seja
desidratação grave, sangramento,
infecção, arritmia, insuficiência
adrenal, entre várias outras. Então, e
não hesite em procurar serviço médico
nessas condições. Para fechar, quero que
você leve três ideias na sua cabeça. Um,
pressão baixa sem sintomas, pode ser só
o seu normal. Dois, quando há sintoma, a
fórmula é hidratação, mas movimentos
inteligentes, mais alimentação ajustada
e compressão muscular e revisão de
causas. Três, quando necessário, há
medicações eficazes, mas elas entram
depois que o básico está redondo. Com
pequenas mudanças consistentes, dá para
virar esse jogo. E me conta qual desses
passos você vai testar primeiro amanhã
de manhã. Eu apostarei no copo de água,
na cabeceira e nas manobras de contração
simples, baratas e que já fazem
diferença no corpo real, da vida real.
M.